everyone welcome to eg live I'm Leon
Aguilera coming to you live from guys
first of all very it's very grand it's
so good to see you here and not stuck in
the speedforce
yeah there's various difference yeah I
have another yeah I'm grant I play Barry
he is still stuck um how are we gonna
see how long is he gonna be stuck work
can you just tell us immediately when
he's coming out I will tell you when we
pick up our story that the Cisco here it
has been this is yes that's right now I
just let's just go there so Carlos here
who plays Cisco has been working on
something to get buried well sister so
yeah Carlos is the actor disco well did
you read the script all right but I'm
saying we all been working well you I'm
just saying he had nobody knew about
with your Caesar salad very still the
Speed Force and the sheen cares about
getting him out I really fell in love
with this Welles
oh that's that's nice of you did I tell
you to say that like it's another thing
today did I lose money you pay later
I know what's really nice is like now
that I'm not in the show anymore these
guys are such good friends of mine that
they let me do Comicon always well I get
I get to stay on a couch and it's like
it's been it's been kind of like old
time so Great Falls we're gonna be
seeing it what I just want to know
is is gonna be a brand new earth
doppelganger are we gonna be sticking
with Harry the nice thing about do
having a show that has a multiverse is
that you can create at any point you can
create an additional 10 15 19 wells as
should you want that and we know the
public does wait what that's what you
call after you call lobbing a softball
and nobody wants that enough talking
about you and under the next question
look at amazing in this cosplay do you
want it you want to explain it this way
well for Americans its Where's Waldo but
in Australia in the UK where where is
Bali in this next season what's yep oh
yeah I think well he's really had to
step up like the whole team has and just
like sort of come into his own I think
that's like one thing like with his like
age and also just the position that
they've also been thrown into well I
think he's finding his way yeah suddenly
felt like my torso was long first time
in a while that both of your kids are
around they're not in any danger does
that mean that he can finally take a
breath in this season kids are always
gonna be so whether it be a metahuman
supervillain or just regular everyday
[Music]
I will never relax I think that we can
all relax a little bit right now because
seems like killer frost has taken a
little bit of a turn we realized that
she isn't quite as evil as we thought
she was she's got a little bit of a
heart that's warming up in there what
can you tease for her journey hmm
I mean I don't know I don't know if we
know that killer frost is gone like I
think there's still a lot of different
places that it could go hopefully
Kaitlyn strong but we don't know she
didn't want to take the metahuman cure
why do you think that is I don't know I
mean I think she thought she could fight
it herself and you know have her own
journey with it but she had to do it
away from team flash which was very sad
homegirl could never keep a love
interest know when the broke and not are
we gonna see here maybe keep one this
year yeah single for a little bit what
we do know that if slush when Barry gets
out of the Speed Force we've got a
wedding to plan you guys yeah uh Candice
put me on the spot right now what do you
think the iris is dream wedding looks
like I don't know um someone joked
earlier about a Speed Force a little
destination wedding I'm inviting all of
our friends across the multiverse
mucinous before it's real quick like two
seconds there we can eat UN's beat you
out don't worry about airfare nothing
like that we got you
[Applause]
lots of dancing and singing of course we
get the engagement last year we'll get
the wedding this year but iris is so
much more than just Barry's girlfriend
that she is so much more than just
various love interest and what can we
expect from her this year I want to see
her more extra news I want to see her
really get into it shame sad news I
don't know if that's the direction we're
going okay iris unfortunately I am what
I cover from HR five episodes right but
where we do find iris season four she's
kind of stepped up Barry's gone she's
kind of become the leader in a sense for
team flash we see her kind of at the
mantle like helping everyone fight crime
in Central City it's it's really cool to
see her in that role and we'll see a lot
of that this season I love that I'm
getting I don't like overwatch vibes
like Felicity Smoak because I think you
feel feels great I mean it's always
great seeing women on our show have
agency I've spoken about that a lot over
the last three seasons so having iris
have agency is always at the forefront
for me here's my question just being a
member of team flash y'all getting paid
for that I think we do that we did I
decided that when the first yeah he left
everything about there
Barry pays us very generously I did not
have to take his diamond what are you
I think some things for himself you
can't do that I stopped me it's out of
my control
but when I stepped in that oh you're
right there's a difference to address
people address that is cut the mania all
right by the way Game of Thrones is
waiting out there that's so weird like
those guys I think I'm letting the can I
think they are wait I think that's what
I would well whose fault is that okay go
again
look once you're good enough to say
shame you guys don't like each other
what what would you like to see
Francisco this year do you think he's
gonna challenge is there gonna be I
think you know he's got to dance more
you know I think we we got to see him
you know loosen up a little bit last
year you know the circumstances were
challenging him to such a degree that he
had to just you know sort of move out of
himself a little bit but I think I'd
love to see him like definitely do a lot
more a dance it out yeah I used to turn
loosely you know I just threw my back
out doing oh yeah in what I'm assuming
I'm let's be honest across super is
gonna happen this year
wouldn't you like to see Cisco and
Jeremy Jordan's character on Supergirl
win come together because they both the
very cheeky techie they've both got a
lot of gadgets everyone have great
voices this is true hi yeah so that's
what I'm saying like but I think we I
think we did the musical crossover I
love to do another one but I don't know
maybe this time you can do yeah not now
not now I love you gonna do another one
I just saw it more too did you
now but what is the one thing that you
do want to say to the flash fans before
they tune in to this new season what
should they know thank you thank you for
watching I think last year got pretty
dark and you know it's like it's dark as
we want to take the show so that's
exactly so we're making a conscious
effort to make it a lot lighter this
year we don't have another speedster as
a villain yes Wow very good that
question yes um would we ever have a
female villain on the show we've had
like female because who knows like she
would know how to fight though how to
fight her
we're a little further along I think
didn't bury enough yeah yeah not much
but yeah how's it been daunting whatever
it's doable guys we're all like episode
three and then Danielle just real
quickly congratulations a marriage
[Applause]
anyways lastly who is a character in a
crossover that you would like to see
your character interact with I mean I
have but I always say Brandon Ralph just
because I like working with him he's
great
Caity Lotz era like she's a dear friend
of mine and she just said you yeah we
want to work with each other
wait who did Brandon's I mean I think I
haven't done a lot of work with like
super girls yeah we do yeah Dave
Perewitz hilarious yeah I think we'll
stick around there yes a definitely
thank you all so much for stopping by I
could talk with you all day but we got a
run just like the flash thank you so
much thank you all fans for tuning in
keep it locked to ET online all day and
et's Facebook page we're coming to you
live to bring you amazing cast like this
and we'll see you next time